there is far more to izalith than what
we've covered on this channel go back
forbidden be these paths the realm of
the creatures of chaos they accept their
banished fate this isn't just a place
that was twisted by the birth of chaos
this is a place that embraced it and
birthed a unique culture in the process
within its walls is a tortured family
yes but one that is far more whole than
we ever gave them credit for a
civilization that went to war with the
wider world one that may have even made
a pact a truce with their enemies those
who defy the pact those who trespass
quail ax domain may you feel the depth
of our rough there is so much left to
discover and not just in the cut content
but in the translations of these games
this video is actually almost entirely
based upon the theories of Hawkshaw who
is another youtuber who is one of the
first to portray demons in a far more
civilised and cultured light it also
features heavily the translations of
Loki a talented writer who has
contributed some of his own theories on
top of hawk Shores we start of course
with izalith the witch of izalith one of
the four Lords who found an ineffable
soul from the first flame is actually
just named izalith in the Japanese text
there is a point where qual onna
simply refers to her as mother izalith
and the developers often used terms like
izalith children when talking about the
witch in interviews the city was still
named after her but as those who knew
the witch as simply izalith dwindled so
too did use of her name now this second
point I'm going to make pretty much
forms the entire foundation for this
video this is our claim it was izalith
ambition not her desperation which led
to the creation of the chaos flame it's
a very commonly held assumption that the
witch of izalith
to duplicate the first flame in an
effort to replace it and while it is a
fact that she did duplicate the first
flame it's incorrect for us to assume
that she did this to replace the fading
first flame in truth the Japanese only
really claims that the witch attempted
to create the fire not replace it and
it's far more likely that the witch in
fact simply wanted a fire of beginning
for herself
in addition whenever sources talk about
this recreation of the first flame they
don't mention I has a list of ocean to
Gwynn's age of fire they don't mention
her having this fear of a fading flame
they reference her ambition and as we'll
explore it makes way more sense for the
chaos flame to be a failed product of
izalith ambition early in the age of
fire rather than this late product of
desperation when the age of fire was
fading more proof of her ambitions may
well be surrounding the ruins of lost
izalith I'm talking about the lower
halves of Dragons the Japanese name is
that which fails to become which is a
parallel to all the other serpentine
creatures that failed to become dragons
and it's more evidence that izalith
attempted to recreate an ancient dragon
which is something that many other
characters in the series ended up trying
to do and it's pretty much a hallmark of
the most ambitious characters of the
series when izalith samba shion's did
push her to create a first flame she
eventually lost control of it and became
the bed of chaos in : as gemonese
dialogue instead of saying that they
turned into deformed creatures she
actually says that her mother and
sisters were transformed into a seed bed
of grotesque life this of course leaves
very little doubt that the bed of chaos
is fused with izalith
at least two of her daughters and not
only are these two daughters fused with
the mother it's also likely that they
helped to bring chaos under control
at its core chaos is parasitic its
creatures are commonly this merging of
two beings but that's not to say that
chaos has complete control over its host
in fact the bed of chaos may well be an
example of this first let's establish
that each side of the bed of chaos is a
daughter of chaos and then will
establish that they are helping to
control chaos when we breach each side
notice how we walk through this mass of
bright orange runes
these are runes that are shared with the
other children of chaos such as quail
egg and ceaseless extending upwards from
here are these long straight staffs
which are very much like the izalith
staffs that are wielded by the daughters
of chaos in the opening cutscene and two
staffs in particular are held by each of
the daughters on either side of the
witch here after we sever a link the
avatar of chaos breaks free and it lords
over this feminine mother figure who has
been feebly swatting us away this whole
time
so if the avatar of chaos can break free
of its bonds then it logically follows
that izalith and her two daughters
brought chaos under control in the first
place and Miyazaki says as much in his
design works interview when he says that
ceaseless discharge was born when the
chaos flame was still not stable and
again what logically follows is that the
chaos flame did stabilize at some point
all of this it really helps us immensely
when we're trying to set up a timeline
because it suggests that there are
stages to the chaos that erupted in
izalith there was the cataclysmic
creation of the cows flame and and there
was a period afterwards where the flame
became somewhat stable ceaseless is our
proof he's a demon that was created
closer to chaos than anyone and it's
clear that he is far more afflicted as a
result our next claim that follows is
that the first demons that came after
ceaseless were born of a more stable
flame
and that this allowed for these
creatures to be a little bit more
sentient let's talk about fire sorceries
pyromancy and the demons associated with
it with the birth of chaos came chaos
pyromancy and then there was pyromancy
after that but before that there were
fire arts which were sorceries and there
were also the sorcerers that mastered
them in the english text the demon fire
sage is said to be at once the last
master of the original fire arts and
also the first demon however this can't
quite be true cannon we just established
that ceaseless was born while the cow's
flame was still unstable so how could
the game be stating that this sage is
also the first demon consider instead
the Japanese text Japanese is often
really vague when it's talking about
whether something is singular or plural
and we have run into this problem before
so instead the description could be read
as the fire priests of demons were among
the first demons and among the last
users of fire sorceries and the demon
fire sage himself is actually more
accurately a fire priest of demons which
is a far more fitting name for not just
this demon but this type of demon and
for there to be fire sages or fire
priests at all it's a way more
convincing argument for this rich
culture that izalith developed after the
mother forced some control over chaos
after all pyromancy is one of the most
important things that izalith brought to
the world and it only happened as a
result of the chaos flame Dark Souls
threes izalith staff states that with
the birth of the chaos flame the flame
witches were at once both sorcerers and
shamans they weren't obliterated by
chaos they were just changed by it and
their fire arts appear to have acquired
this element of faith which may well be
related to these demonic fire priests
which may well have later become
pyromancy so continuing on from
pyromancy the English text claims that
qual Anna is the mother of pyromancy and
that izalith is the godmother of
pyromancy but the Japanese text actually
uses the same term for both these women
calling them founders or pioneers of
pyromancy the word founder is also used
for Seif who is the founder of sorcery
the izalith pyromancy tome goes on to
state that chaos pyromancies led to all
later forms so surely the daughters of
chaos were all intrinsic to the
development of this pyromancy possibly
Dark Souls 3 does support this the white
hair talisman says that the witches of
chaos were founders of pyromancy so for
COO alana to be so versed in pyromancy
did she really escape immediately after
her mother and sisters were turned into
the bed of chaos because that's the way
she always made it sound
kalana talks a lot about the anguish of
her family how she escaped and how they
need to be freed from chaos but all
other evidence suggests that she at
least helped them struggle with the
initial outburst of chaos and I don't
think it's possible she just sees them
as mere monsters cual Anna's robes are
actually dressed upon a corpse which is
upon an altar in front of her brother
ceaseless discharge which suggests that
she faked her death to escape because
Wiles with this corpse be upon an altar
and why would you fake your death to
creatures that you think are just base
monsters the answer is that she can't
have left immediately because ceaseless
cares about his sister as his rage
clearly shows because when you desecrate
her corpse and steal the robes off of it
that's when he attacks
no it's very likely that these two had a
connection built after the chaos
engulfed izalith after all it was his
elder sisters plural who had sympathy
for him and attempted to ease his pain
with an orange chard ring there is room
for a really really tragic story about
quail Anna and the legacy that she left
behind but this isn't the video for it
so remember to subscribe if you want to
see it someday
so as you should be able to tell from
this point that there is a far stronger
argument for an organized intelligent
demon culture than there is against it
I'm gonna rattle off a bit more evidence
though first becoming a demon may have
been something of an optional process
the exception being izalith and
ceaseless all of whom were brought into
being when the chaos flame was still
unstable
so consider quelaag and the fair lady
who are not described as among the first
demons like ceaseless 'as Quelaag
strokes her abdomen affectionately in
the cutscene showing no resentment for
what she's become the fair lady
apologizes to her sister for the death
of her eggs displaying this desire for
demon kind to grow the agama fuge states
that egg bearers chose to serve the
flame of chaos chaos servants can even
access a secret path that makes travel
more convenient and many demons
sacrifice humanity in order to serve
chaos not just the humanity of others of
course like quail egg does but many of
these creatures might have been humans
beforehand the Capra and Taurus demons
actually drop humanity and the Capra
demon has the intelligence to train the
beasts that serve it Miyazaki has even
gone on record praising the Capra demons
design saying that this goat head has
this sense of ceremony and long-held
tradition there is even a hierarchy
among demons almost a monarchy lesser
demons greater demons fire priests
Prince's a king
and you might even want to call izalith
for Queen there is a language a script
there are ancient smithing techniques as
shown by the chaos flame ember and also
quail Anna who is a daughter of Kaos who
is closer to the bed of chaos than
anyone and yet she shows no signs of
transformation after the initial
engulfment transformation may well have
been less about proximity and more about
choice demons are not simple monsters in
anguish as quail Anna would have us
believe and were it not for the war that
Gwyn waged upon them perhaps demon kind
would have a far better foothold on the
world than when we encountered them this
war against the demons is referenced in
the Black Knight weapons which were
forged to counter the tremendous size of
their demonic adversaries and it's clear
that izalith was on the losing side of
this war considering that the Japanese
text refers to the city as the obsolete
capital of chaos all this said though
demon kind wasn't completely obliterated
the capital is again only referenced as
obsolete it's no longer a threat to
humanity or Gwynn's age of fire it's
just this broken civilization that's
devoid of humans and quietly incubating
its next generation through the egg
bearers therefore words from quail eggs
cut dialogue about the demons seems
likely to remain true Quelaag also
speaks of a pact those who defy the pact
those who trespass quail acts domain may
you feel the depth of her ruff the gods
bowed out of the war with the demons in
a really dominant position that's for
sure they were even able to swell their
own ranks with demon kind placing them
in key positions the lesser bad winged
demons for example wield lightning and
fairy key messengers around the kingdom
of the god
and the fiercest demons were just left
to fulfill their nature guarding and
executing unwanted undead from those
kept in the asylum of Dark Souls one to
those trapped in the undead settlement
of Dark Souls 3 it's also quite likely
that when Gwyn bowed out of the war
against the demons it might have been
because he had a more pressing concern
than a drawn-out war there was the rise
of another culture that is far more
chaotic than even demons were the abyss
if this video is received well then
there is room for a video on them as
well for now I'm going to direct you to
hawk Shores video on demons which offers
quite a few more unique theories than
have been presented here but anyway I'm
really glad for the opportunity to get
everyone up to speed on this channel
about how demons are more of a cultured
force so thank you for watching
finally let's talk one last time about
discord about a week ago we had this
huge PvP tournament where thousands of
you guys competed in the arena for
prizes and attempted to kill me in the
end only three people got the best of me
and I managed to kill 16 people so it's
a pretty good win-loss ratio discord
Channel was crazy active and it pretty
much has been for the last few weeks so
please come and join our community be a
part of the growth of not only our
channel but the best voice chat program
on the market Fox Co also there might be
a few impromptu PvP tournaments coming
up which you can only get in on if you
join also for patrons I'm gonna do one
for you guys as well that's just open to
our private discord so thanks again for
watching this video guys go and check
out Hawkshaw go and check out discord
and I'll see you next time
[Music]